liberal City accused of misguided
priorities New York City's mayor
recently warned his City could be
destroyed by the migrant crisis and how
the influx could cost the city a
whopping 12 billion dollars by 2025 but
never mind that some local leaders think
statues are the real problem New York
City council members are laser focused
on creating a reparations task force to
among other things remove statues of
people tied to slavery from city
property
this bill is part of an overall effort
to really address historical injustices
it looks at the landscape of New York
City the public space we have I don't
see this as anything other than an act
of moving forward in a positive way a
proactive approach towards addressing
um art and public spaces and trying to
have a conversation about how do we move
forward statues of George Washington and
Christopher Columbus could be on the
chopping block Jesse sent Johnny down to
interview the council members about
their proposal
did you want to remove the statues it
depends Christopher Columbus
it depends I'm about like truth-telling
he discovered America there are a lot of
people that I feel he did many harms and
statutes and monuments tend to honor
people the Italians are going to be very
upset I've heard that he wasn't even
like Italian you want to remove the
statues rename the Christopher Columbus
statue to what
a miracle Vespucci so you so you're just
saying all white guys look the same
no I'm not saying that Columbus Columbus
was a bad guy wow now they're going to
see Johnny coming Jesse and think oh boy
here we go so the woman he interviewed
said she didn't even know Columbus was
Italian how stupid are you she's trying
to destroy this guy because why because
he discovered America Italians are going
to be mad he sailed under the Spanish
Crown but he's Italian she doesn't even
know what she's talking about so instead
they're going to put a plaque as like a
peace offering and it's ten thousand
dollars to say in small letters that
Columbus was a bad guy do you think
that's solving the problems Dana migrant
crises we have a crime wave and they're
going to tear down statues in this
country the Italians aren't going to put
up with it and the rest of red-blooded
America is not going to put up with it
George Washington
Thomas Jefferson are you kidding me do
we even belong to the same country she
should be proud of George Washington and
Thomas Jefferson without these two men
we wouldn't have a country then we
wouldn't have any statues to tear down
do you know the other thing that happens
at the Columbus statue
um in Columbus Circle there's the statue
and then there's the circle do you know
what is all around there homeless like
they like they care so much about the
area you know the amazing part of it
Dana is that um
we didn't learn from what happened in
California so Gavin Newsom puts together
this reparations committee to to assess
what they should do about the past
injustices and they come back and say
you should give everybody this amount of
money that amount of money this amount
of money and then he comes out and he
says it's much more than about a cash
payment because she doesn't want to give
him the money so now we're in the middle
of a migrant crisis we can't even afford
it the mayor is complaining about it and
what we want to do is assess the New
York City Council wants to assess what
we should do for reparation so by the
way that little plaque that's ten
thousand dollars why not just put a
Scarlet Letter on it I mean because
that's what is these are really bad
people why don't people look at history
in terms of history in terms of the time
what was going on at that time put
things in context maybe they did do good
things all right and going forward does
that mean these same people will be
willing to say in 40 years I was wrong
in 2023 because I didn't look at it the
right way as I'm looking at it in 2063.
Harold when you say think about all the
problems that they're that exist in
government today and you are triaging a
situation where the mayor says we have
to cut 25 billion dollars in services to
the city while the trash is not even
picked up on the streets right now is
this the highest and best use of our
time and taxpayer dollars no
um but I listened to the uh to the
councilwoman and it it you think about
the challenges we face in our Public
Schools you think about the migrant
issues that we talk about uh you think
about the mental health issues that we
talk about on this show many many in our
city are dealing with you think about
the crime
um I understand where the councilwoman
is coming from but they're far bigger
issues that we need to be we need to be
focused on I believe two
um
our history is complex it's a
beautifully complex story known as
America they're in unsavory things and
unbelievable things in our past they're
incredible things and incredulous things
that have happened in America's history
we shouldn't be afraid of any of it we
should want to learn it understand it
and figure out how we don't repeat the
same mistakes and how we grow from it
and I hope that as much as the passion I
heard from some who want these statues
removed redirect some of that passion
those of you in government to try to
figure out how we make sure we don't
repeat some of the challenges or some of
the problems we face today and one one
thing that's going to help us repeat it
which is unfortunate if we don't if we
don't teach and educate our kids we
don't make our streets safe and we don't
find ways to protect our border these
history shows if you can't do those
things as Jefferson once said any nation
that wants to be free and ignorant at
the same time
will be a nation that never never has
never happened before in the history of
the world that's what we should be
focused on not removing statues and
Harold that was George Jefferson
well he wasn't moving he was moving on
up he was moving I love his statue yeah
you know this is so unfair Dana if you
remove those statues from Columbus
Circle where will the CNN staffers
urinate I don't know it's a good
question
um so where should the statues go I
think red States should declare
themselves statue sanctuaries right yeah
we said you the illegals we'll take the
statues and there should be no cash bail
for these statues so once you pick them
up you better let them go Pacer remind
New York leaders that Statues by
definition are stationary they can't
move which means they don't rape they
don't Rob they don't push women in front
of subway trains no statue ever did a
smash and grab at a Walgreens or beat an
elderly man unconscious I'm sure however
if you say that removing statues will do
nothing to reduce crime the left will
say no you're wrong the statues are
emblematic of the of the oppression that
led to this type of activity officer
officer I beat that Asian woman to a
bloody pulp after seeing that statue of
Columbus I demand Justice and
reparations we'll see if you get them
that's just kind of reparations
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else